The Fallout of a domestic dispute is
caught on camera in California after a
man reportedly Cuts up his bed with a
knife and threatens to kill somebody
in on it
the incident unfolded on August 29th in
Los Angeles just before three o'clock
that afternoon 9-1-1 dispatch received a
call from a woman barricaded inside her
closet what's the emergency
um I don't know I think my boyfriend's
having like a mental breakdown and he
has uh he does have a knife
uh 42. okay
at the walls
don't hang up are you in a safe place
right now yeah I came to my closet
okay all right don't hang up okay
the caller told dispatch she'd never
seen her boyfriend act that way before
and wasn't sure what led up to his
Outburst no we did we had some beers we
were just hanging out I mean for food
and then I don't know I don't know what
happened
as you just started like you know
writing myself
uh no not nothing that I know
yeah yes
we only had beers I don't think he took
anything else
it's an apartment
I've never seen him like this as she
details the incident to First Responders
the man can be heard yelling in the
background of the call you don't know
what caused this right
right no no I I was thinking we had some
you know I was making food I woke up
made some margaritas we're just drinking
chilling and then I don't know where he
just started exploding
yeah
closet
because he threw like he threw tears he
threw everything on the floor and then
he had a knife and then he cut the bed
never never
hang up one moment
the caller describes the man as police
are sent to the scene and it's
Hispanic
he's hispanic
today
he's wearing he's wearing some Army
shorts
no shirt no no shirt
142.
what's his name
um
the suspect in the case was later
identified as 42 year old Jose Cuellar
body camera video shows LAPD officers
arrive on the scene and almost
immediately Cuellar slams the door in
their faces
nothing
situation
response
seconds later a woman opens the door and
police enter the apartment
a handful of officers rushed through the
door meeting Cuellar at the end of a
hallway they begin by shouting commands
quaiar begins yelling in Spanish telling
officers to shoot him
ma'am back
I'm back
hey
toys
[Laughter]
as First Responders confirm they're
armed with a 40 millimeter less Lethal
Weapon they also determine a
Spanish-speaking officer should lead the
conversation with Cuellar you got 40.
stop right there
this video shows the same moments from
another perspective
stop right there
stop get on the ground now get on the
ground now get on the ground I've gotta
switch switch
hey switch hey yeah
the story then begins to unfold as
Cuellar believes officers will arrest
him speaking about issues with his
family
foreign
[Music]
First Responders continue to comfort
Cuellar saying they want to offer help
that's when he brings up a specific
incident with his significant other hey
follow somebody
cilantro
okay
meanwhile other officers speak with the
woman inside the home who describes what
led up to the incident
like this
[Applause]
what's going on
um
I've been with him eight years I've
never seen him like this ever ever he
hasn't hurt me but she got my knife
um
he wanted to kill
people
any weapons or anything on them you guys
just want to grab them
hey does he have anything else does he
have anything else
so which one was he stabbing the bedroom
officials then determine it's a mental
health emergency as Cuellar details his
issue alleging someone else is
communicating with his significant other
no crimes
at this point cuer does not appear to
have any weapons in his hand but First
Responders warn him if he picks up a
kitchen knife they will fire the last
Lethal Weapon I don't see any knife
foreign
but seconds later Cuellar picks up a
knife
at that point an officer fires the less
lethal round hey no the round hits
cuellar's wrist and he drops the knife
into a nearby trash can
body camera video from another officer
shows these same moments from a
different angle is
[Music]
foreign
then buttercup
Amigos
thank you
it's then cuer is taken into custody
Cuellar was later taken to the hospital
to be treated for a laceration on his
wrist and a fracture he was later booked
for an outstanding and unrelated warrant
out of the nearby City right now the use
of force incident is still under
investigation reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie